c'est une science presque un art ces
morceaux de boeuf ont passé plus d'un
mois dans une cave réfrigérée comme le
fromage le bon vin faire vieillir la
viande demande rigueur et précision ce
processus d'affinage va permettre en
fait de sublimer certaines
caractéristiques ce qu'on appelle
organoleptiques alors l'organe oleksy
miss et la saveur c'est la texture c'est
le goût c'est l'odeur est donc ça va
surtout sublimer la tendreté de la
viande ainsi que le goût cette
maturation elle peut prendre
elle commence de à peu près à partir de
dix jours et elle peut aller jusqu'à 30
40 50 voire pour certains certains cas
bien particuliers 120 jours certains
bouchers pousse même la maturation
jusqu'à un an
l'hygiène est soigneusement contrôlée
les spécialistes joue entre les
différents paramètres dans les caves de
maturation la température l'hygrométrie
et le temps il faut la conserver
vraiment danser car là puisque ces
câbles à vont permettre une meilleure
ventilation une meilleure aération et
puis une homogénéité de température et
d'hygrométrie qui est vraiment très
importante pour réaliser ce process de
maturation toute viande ne se prête pas
à la maturation déjà ce sont les
morceaux les plus nobles
vous allez avoir la côte de boeuf
l'entrecôte principalement et des
morceaux qui contiennent un minimum de
graisse intramusculaire ce qu'on appelle
le persuade le père sillage est
important car la viande père de son os
et le gras se répartit dans les fibres
du muscle et donne ce goût si
particulier pour un kilo de ce mets
d'exception compter entre 35 à 75 euros
selon les boucheries les produits les
plus nobles peuvent grimper à plus de
1000 euros